this video was made possible by news
voice a democratized news app created to
fight back against the filter bubbles
caused by corporate media download for
free from news voice calm slash Pakman
or click the link under this video I
told you yesterday that when it was one
sexual assault accuser against Brett
Kavanaugh Republicans wanted to play the
game they said let's have a hearing
let's hear from both sides
not because they were actually
considering not voting to confirm Brett
Kavanaugh but because they figured it
would be very easy to just let Christine
Blasi Ford show up say what she wants to
say and then Republicans could take the
position that listen we heard from her
we gave her a hearing we still see no
reason to hold up Brett Kavanaugh as
confirmation let's vote and let's put
Brett Kavanaugh in but then as I told
you yesterday a second accuser came
forward and then allegations of even
more accusers and more people with
knowledge of Brett Kavanaugh s alleged
actions came forward and then I told you
yesterday Republicans now are going to
ignore these accusers because otherwise
it will hold up the nomination if they
take these allegations seriously so in
other words if it's just Christine Blasi
Ford and they pretend that it's only
Christine Blasi Ford you do want hearing
and you get beyond it once there are two
accusers once there are three accusers
and people who say Marc judge Brett
Cavanaugh's friend was involved in this
stuff and his college roommate says it
sounds like this is the type of stuff
you would be involved in you can't
acknowledge the existence of all of that
all of those accusers without holding up
the process because it would become very
I've evident that you know that those
accusers exist and yet you are
continuing to just push forward we even
learned from the New Yorker in their
article about accuser number two Deborah
Ramirez that Republicans were told about
her allegations last week and the
reaction was not oh what this is serious
let's hear from her their reaction was
to try to vote even sooner to get Brett
Kavanaugh on the Supreme Court
as soon as humanly possible
of all that we knew all about yesterday
the news that we learned about since
yesterday's show is that we were right
and not to pat ourselves on the back it
was very obvious that this was what
Republicans were doing Republicans have
entered full ignore mode yesterday
finally they got a call scheduled with
the Senate Judiciary Committee to speak
to Debra Ramirez his lawyer John Clun
and even getting the call on the
calendar took forever every single time
that it looked like they were finally
going to have a call with Republicans
Democrats and Debra Ramirez his lawyer
Republicans would show up and they would
add some new requirements they would say
well if we're going to have the call we
need to have this list of evidence
presented to us in advance or if we're
going to get on the call we need a full
list of the questions that does
such-and-such right they kept placing
roadblocks and moving the goalposts
finally Republicans agreed yesterday to
have a conference call at 7:00 p.m. last
night sort of an unusual time but okay
they agreed to it the time for the phone
call comes ramirez's attorney calls in
democrats from the Senate Judiciary get
on the call and no Republicans show up
they simply didn't call into the
conference call period Skipton Debra
Ramirez is lawyer says that quote every
time we try to set up a phone call the
majority party meaning Republicans
either changes the rules of the phone
call or they want additional information
as a condition of even having the phone
call with us here he is on CNN last
night explaining that this can't be
handled in this way this doesn't make
any sense I think the first thing that's
that's critical Anderson is that this
has to be investigated by meaningful law
enforcement this is not something that
can be done by either the Senate or some
hired gun prosecutor than once across
today I'm you know either miss Ford or
or miss Ramirez this has to be by FBI
who can investigate the matter with a
threat of perjury our clients willing to
do that I'd be very interested to see
whichever witnesses judge Cavanaugh
actually has remaining who are willing
to talk if they were willing to do the
same thing so if we can get a meaningful
in from investigation by the FBI there
are all sorts of ways that our client be
willing to provide in
Meishan to the center he's right this
should be a much bigger thing than it is
it should be the FBI that's
investigating all of this but
Republicans are winning they are winning
because they are simply not engaging
they are ignoring the fact that the
number of accusers is building the
number of character defenders of the
accusers and character detractors of the
accused are building and coming out of
the woodwork and meanwhile they've
scheduled to vote to confirm Brett
Kavanaugh at the committee level for
this Friday at 9:30 Eastern that is
their plan they have already decided
that Friday at 9:30 regardless of what
happens in tomorrow's hearing with
Christine Blasi Ford they are going to
move forward we have now multiple
accusers who have not been heard we have
Republicans covering their eyes and
plugging their ears and just not calling
in to the scheduled conference call and
then you have chuck Grassley the
Republican who runs the Senate Judiciary
Committee saying hey you know what we're
gonna look at just being ready for a
vote on Friday at 9:30 this is a
potential vote but they did say he did
say that this is what they're looking to
do saying on Twitter Judiciary Committee
noticed potential executive meeting for
a meeting for Friday still taking this
one step at a time
after hearing dr. Ford and Judge
Cavanaugh's testimony if we're ready to
vote we will vote if we aren't ready
we won't committee rules normally
require three days notice so we're
following regular order so that's what
they're hiding behind they're saying
we're not assuming that there's not
going to be anything serious brought up
on Thursday it's just that because you
need this three day notice for the vote
we've put the notice out there so again
it is this constant pressure rush to get
the confirmation done and meanwhile the
evidence continues to mount
there are now four new people who have
offered to speak to the Senate and to
corroborate the story of accuser number
one Christine Blasi Ford USA Today is
reporting that the attorneys for dr.
Ford have sworn and signed declarations
from for people who corroborate her
claims of sexual assault by Supreme
Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
Republicans are already saying oh no
that that doesn't corroborate anything
all those four people are saying is that
dr. Ford told them the same story but
that's not actual evidence and of course
this is really evidence of our broken
system it's not a broken democratic
system it's not a broken judicial system
all of these systems together are badly
broken and we now have a situation where
again it could be that Cavanaugh chooses
to withdraw if he comes up with one of
these explanations like it's getting bad
for my family or whatever Republicans
have made it very clear they are moving
full speed ahead I don't think that
anything will get them to change their
minds unless it's Cavanaugh or Trump who
decide that they're not going forward
with it and that's what I want to hear
from you about we have a poll up on our
YouTube community tab at youtube.com
slash the david pakman show where we are
asking what do you think is ultimately
going to happen with this nomination
we've gone back and forth here about it
looks like this is gonna have no impact
then more accusers come up and we say
you know this does look like it's
starting to put real pressure against
Brett Kavanaugh but then of course
Republicans decide to ignore all of the
accusers except for the first which
makes it much easier to just push
through the nomination where are you on
this right now
it's wilt we're because you would think
more accusers would mean that
Republicans they're much more hesitant
to put this guy through when you would
have to we're seeing the opposite it's
making like more bold
I think they'll they'll do the vote on
what is it Friday yeah and he ultimately
will get confirmed and put on the
Supreme Court for life so the four
people who are wondering about the
schedule if they do the committee vote
on Friday there's no expectation that
they would do the full Senate vote on
Friday that could come maybe as early as
Monday you don't need too many
Republicans to change their votes in
order for him to fail but when it really
comes down to it even someone like Lisa
Murkowski a Republican from Alaska she
said when the first allegations came out
let's slow this down and have a hearing
I still don't know that she would
actually vote against Kavanagh in the
full Senate yeah you only need two
Republicans to flip and it's the usual
suspects it's Lisa Murkowski and Susan
Collins maybe the outgoing Republican
senators like Jeff Flake job corker but
you need the Democrats to hold strong
and you know we got people like Joe
Manchin and John tester don't be worried
about that that's important because when
we say you only need two Republicans to
flip that means that you're assuming not
a single Democrat in the Senate votes
for this guy and typically Democrats do
vote for Republican Supreme Court
nominees and Republicans do vote for
Democratic Supreme Court nominees quite
a few Democrats voted for Neal Gorsuch
yeah I mean maybe there's more
hesitation here but we'll see we'll see
we will see maybe within a four or five
days send me your thoughts make sure you
are following the show on instagram at
david pakman show now regularly posting
content to ig TV as well as
behind-the-scenes pictures polls all
sorts of great stuff that's at david
pakman show on instagram you can also
follow me on instagram at david dot
Pakman
the conclusion to my interview with
former astronaut scott Kelly's coming up
next